[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bon soin
alors nounours tu ne veut toujours pas
me dire ce que tu apportes de si
précieux dans son panier mon bon patron
c'est un cadeau de ma soeur humilia elle
me l'a envoyé pour mes deux petits amis
et je descends leur portée à tout à
l'heure on l'échelle
comme propos plein
boom
bonsoir les enfants naissent
de
gentil d'être en retard
j'apporte un cadeau pour les enfants qui
ont été sages
c'est pour moi car je suis toujours sage
[Musique]
l'a dit
l'ubs
déconfiture
je suis un petit garçon de bella figura
tu veux bien le pompon et les confitures
si vous voulez tout donné je saurai bien
les mots j'ai la bonne aventure au guide
la paix n'est plus roi
lorsque le petit garçon gentil et sage
on leur donne des pompons de jolies
images
ma quote tu ce fut gros t'es là fait ce
trop longs bonnets la triste aventure
hockey notre aventure
je serai sage bien bon pour plaire à ma
mère je serais bien mal son couple
heureux mon père je veux bien les coups
portés et s'il fait le monde le sait la
bonne aventure ok la panne a menti
[Musique]
'nos
d'émerveiller nous aimons tellement les
confitures les seuls à vous m'en direz
des nouvelles
mash up rubia c'est elle qui les a fait
quelques heures dans wii alors quelqu'un
dehors
tu lui diras un grand merci de notre
attaque et tu lui feras un gros baiser
a
connu une manche andy hayman bonne nuit
les petits
la
j'éteins la lumière
[Musique]
adobe
connu nicolas fait beau rêve petite
soeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on 120 patron pas avant que tu m'aies
dis ce que tu as apporté à nicolas et
pimprenelle
du conte futur patron mais rassurez vous
j'en ai caché impôts chez nous et nous
allons bien nous régaler
allons en route gros qu aucun boni les
enfants de pur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh